A lot goes into making a movie — especially
one in the sprawling Marvel Cinematic Universe
— and sometimes directors don't get things
quite right on the first go-around.
Such is the case for Avengers: Endgame and
filmmakers Joe and Anthony Russo, who brought
back Tilda Swinton to reshoot her scene more
than a year after she wrapped on it.
That's right: We haven't exhausted every possible
Endgame topic!
"I understood that reference."
A movie of this magnitude is chock full of
behind-the-scenes secrets.
Spoilers ahead!
Swinton, who plays the Ancient One, appears
during a pivotal moment in the middle of Endgame.
When Professor Hulk and company travel back
in time to 2012 New York City to retrieve
three Infinity Stones as part of their time
heist mission, the green guy pays the Ancient
One a visit at the Sanctum Sanctorum and asks
her to surrender the Time Stone.
While Ant-Man, Captain America, and Iron Man
are off retrieving the Space and Mind Stones,
Professor Hulk is on the receiving end of
a lecture about how one can't just take an
Infinity Stone out of its proper place without
severely damaging the existing timeline.
It's an important scene that establishes how
time travel works in the MCU – but it's
a scene that originally played out differently.
Chatting with IndieWire, Swinton revealed
that the Russo Brothers called her into film
the sequence all over again a year after she
first shot it.
Swinton explained,
"I went back to reshoot it because a couple
of lines had been changed, a couple of plot
points had been changed.
And there was a tweaking of my costume."
As is expected, Swinton couldn't dish up exact
details on what the original take entailed,
though she did state that the reworked plot
points were "all about" the visual timeline
the Ancient One crafts when explaining to
Professor Hulk the rules of time travel and
alternate realities.
She then noted that the alterations centered
around, quote, "the information that the Ancient
One holds about the nature of the [Infinity]
Stones, that they have to be put back."
In the theatrical cut of the film, the Ancient
One goes into great detail about how the timeline
is impacted when someone takes an Infinity
Stone from one point in time and transports
it to another.
That kind of interdimensional tomfoolery creates
a branch timeline that is dark, chaotic, and
doesn't abide by the same laws that the original
timeline does.
This explanation informs the Avengers' decision
to have one team member — Captain America
— return the Stones after they defeat Thanos
at the end of the film.
Swinton also said that the Russo Brothers
changed up the dialogue in her scene to better
connect to Endgame shooting down time travel
rules presented in movies like Back to the
Future and Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure.
"What?
How?”
“Good tea."
Swinton also gushed about her experience working
on Endgame, and said that the double shoot
was more than worth it.
"That was amazing, and a whole other world
of filmmaking.
But, boy, was it worth it.
They tweaked it into something extraordinary."
"Time travel!"
We may never know what the original version
of the Sanctum Sanctorum sequence in Endgame
was like, but it sounds like the reshoot added
some much-needed clarity to the film.
Fans have had a hard time wrapping their heads
around how time travel works within the context
of the MCU in general …
"It's a dumb question."
"Okay.
Got it.
So we all agree it's possible.
Now what?"
… and how time travel works in Endgame specifically,
even with the reshoot, so it's a good thing
the Russos summoned Swinton back to the set.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.